what fireflies get down oh the [ __ ] are
these guys
what's your operon
come on
all right
think we're safe
Oh Joel [ __ ]
ja ah you gotta tell me what to do you
gotta get up
yeah Riley Apple I landed on my hip hell
I thought I was bidden I know it was
grabbed it awesome you're not gonna kill
me are you
I haven't seen you and I don't even know
how long 45 days
well 46 technically want to know what
I've been up to all this time I thought
you were dead
yeah here look
no way still no roommate I had to sleep
under Liz for three years and you know
how bad that girls smell you're a
Firefly
you still have it up what what are you
doing I'm making sure I don't get caught
with a fire flame relax there are no
soldiers on the entire floor here
Congrats hey are we cool are we cool I
disappeared and you're mad and I owe you
an explanation
let's get out of here and I'll tell you
all about it it's almost morning and I
have military drills you know where we
learn how to kill fireflies put some
pants on and let's go I'm so dumb
come on when have we ever gotten into
trouble oh here we go
okay I'll put you on your side
Jesus
I should buy us some time
find something to stitch you up okay
Kalas keep an eye on I'll be back in a
flash
promise that's all I got this
all right now where the [ __ ] do I go
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play the last of us
left behind DLC now I am late to the
game on this one because I was not here
in Cincinnati where all my recording
equipment for this game was on Friday
through Monday and I only just got it
set up today so if you were worried that
I wasn't gonna play it I apologize and
don't worry just because my face wasn't
there for that cutscene does not mean
that it will be absent in the future
ones it was a bit of a long one and I
wanted to give the introduction to the
game it's due moment but either way I'm
back in this game and it's been a long
time since my The Last of Us playthrough
almost seems like ages ago personally
but it actually hasn't been that long in
the in the grand scheme of things so
we're back in the shoes of Ellie the
only time we played Ellie was that
sounds promising
uh-huh probably something to stitch up
Joel now he flashed backwards and
forward throughout the game I don't know
how long we're gonna be in this timeline
or the other one but I mean I thought
that this uh part of the story was a bit
no left out so it's cool that they're
coming back to it but at the same time
there was a sense of mystery just
knowing that Ellie was on her own and
you know she are you miss to survive
then again you know maybe it's gonna go
back and try to investigate how she was
able to get the skills she needed to
survive because when she was a kid well
I mean she's still kid but I mean it
seems like she grew up throughout the
entire story but as she is a kid now or
then rather I'm getting my timelines
picked up thing no that's too bad but
anyway back then she still seemed like
she was um part of the system she was
talking about the soldiers and now the
fireflies which if you don't recall were
the group of people that were originally
trying to help Joel get the Cure but if
you know the end of The Last of Us and
if you don't you can see my playthrough
but I won't mom I don't know but if I
can even save any spoilers at this time
if you haven't seen the playthrough but
you know that's what happened that thing
you know that thing that happened that
thing everyone knows that thing except
those who don't know the thing
but yeah anyway first aid kit yep [ __ ]
do I get inside ahh
watch your mouth young lady obviously
you need a key but what I don't
understand is how in the world that Joel
survived having his intestines impaled
maybe he's uh that doesn't sound good 35
30 31 if you want crazy more than likely
he is already infected and there's
probably not much chance for him thirty
five thirty thirty one thirty thirty
five thirty five thirty thirty one I
think that was it anyway anyway back to
the old system of crafting up supplies
to stab zom zoms with now where oh where
is his back room six and a half hours
later oh yeah that was weird
I totally read that it was in the store
next door and definitely didn't wander
around for about five minutes doing
nothing okay everyone trust me I'm good
okay so I'm looking for the American oh
hello ah my lovely favorite brick I love
the brick breaking absorbs in the head
is my favorite thing to do is that ah is
that some adult film that I don't know
anything about there we go
American princess I got to get in here
maybe I could smash through the window
with my brick no oh maybe I could just
open the front door like a bohemian 35
right thirty five thirty thirty one
thirty five thirty thirty one well it's
probably hold it my apologies I was
wrong in that endeavor
I was mashing it I don't even remember
oh oh yeah I'm immune
I don't need to worry about that
you're gonna jump out of me going do it
no how about no how about a big a no on
that one I'm proud of the job God it's
not gonna jump out of me
this looks fun so I'm guessing that if
as arms are MS oh it's gonna jump
it's gonna jump like yep okay um run and
run and run run run run
okay [ __ ] all right damn it
okay so anyway that was my guess yeah
pharmacy righty-ho
oh he had a family your wife at least or
a girlfriend at the bare minimum oh this
place is creepy so anyway if its arms up
because this is all fungal infections
and not traditional
who's driving I got goddamn it you need
not be worried I'm gonna brick yeah damn
it I forgot that I forgot how to play
give me a second
[ __ ] and then I knife you gotcha
there we go I remember not dying
immediately like I usually do in these
playthroughs it is coming back to me I
do remember how to play it's just been a
while so anyway back in here now we need
to get in the back to try to get that
first-aid kit for mr. Joel over there
Rose Ayers does guy you want to look
uh-oh
nope don't know what to tell you a
military helicopter Oh handy that why
didn't I just jump through the window
before oh okay well thank you for the
conveniently placed Supply Drop I like
your spunk all right how do I get over
there well which way is it Miss Ellie
I'm not entirely sure now it has been a
while since I played a game like this in
that it wasn't just like a one-shot
indie game with a silly premise you know
I actually don't play too many hundred
percent serious games and when I do I
really do try to take it seriously yeah
so don't expect any stupid jokes which
is basically like 99% of everything I
say and other stuff she could even call
him jokes but for this one I really
loved when I first play through this
story of in the actual emotion that I
felt when I was playing it and sometimes
connection like that to a real you know
feeling that you get from a story as
opposed to just a fun experience is
rewarding in its own right and I don't
know sometimes I feel like doing this
let's play compromises some of that that
disgusting bandage that was like brown
and grody you say I guess Joel can't
complain but he can be infected but
anyway what was I saying
oh saying something about being serious
but I've no idea ah ah I forgot about
that
gosh achy shaky battery let's check it
you guys you gonna jump out from there
here we go there we go sorry anyway what
I'm saying is that up here
maybe hold off on that time oh I was
close huh you got a fast there I'm
impressed
okay cool Thanks well come on up we go
all right I didn't think it'd take us
too much out of the game did you find
them the fireflies yeah
remember that Firefly you bitten stole
his gun yeah I remember him that's
Trevor I saw him walking down the street
so I tailed his ass I follow him into
this alley and all these fireflies
ambushed me huh they took me right to
their hideout
- Marlene yeah were you scared terrified
I thought this time she would actually
shoot me Hey
but I said she just says what took you
so long no she was expecting me okay and
she just made you a Firefly
something like that hmm that whole
almost kill anything retest she wanted
to know I was committed hmm oh it's
weird test I'm wondering if this girl is
actually related to Marlene cuz they
kind of look similar maybe not a hundred
percent but some similarities there
anyway what I was saying before there's
a lot of dialogue in this game which is
part of what I was trying to say is it I
feel like doing Let's Plays like this
kind of detracts from the experience so
I try to be not so much just a
reactionary facecam whatever I just try
to be a guide through these games much
as I can have you found the light yet no
oh har har
oh I'm sorry I didn't mean to offend
your people so what you buy into this
whole thing now all I know is that I'm
not a soldier mm-hmm yay people are
getting affected all the time they just
do a good job of hiding it yeah
you've run into more infected oh that's
part of my initiation I actually made me
kiss no talk about Oh okay so this is
actually the original city that they
were in the quarantine zone imagine
feeling really weird to live in a
situation where every day you could be
infected by a fungus and driven insane
although at the same time it seems a bit
more organized than most zombie
apocalypses maybe I should join the
Firefly state that it Mele yeah that was
the first thing I asked my marine she
wants you safe at that stupid school I'm
not even supposed to come see you uh-huh
why does she care yeah she's worried
I'll get you into trouble yeah whatever
I can get into trouble just fine on my
own
yeah oh I know mm-hmm okay that was good
talk right there so I mean coming into
the city again I actually am look trying
to think back I don't remember exploring
it all that mammoth awesome I brought
you here no what are we doing here Riley
yeah what I have a surprise for you
what's that what
is it a dinosaur maybe moving your
friend again if it's a dinosaur he'll
just have to wait and see I hope it's a
dinosaur I love dinosaurs
hey mannequins that was looking at me
funny
so Howard dinosaur mannequin
either way is it gonna kill us cuz I've
had bad experiences with those before
I can't believe Winston's gone maybe you
heard yeah do you know how it happened
zombie they said he just fell off his
horse heart attack or something why not
man well how many people get to die of
natural causes in this world oh it's
true none that I know of
mmm exactly yeah so let's see what he
left us okay really
oh I get it oh so this old guy was
camping out in the middle of nowhere
here that's interesting
what do we have here some old magazines
what hey is this Winston Rand guy used
to be handsome what not a Winston
awesome sure I'll take it all right
party on
please oh oh wait no oh my god oh here
that's disgusting
ha ha ha cheers Winston underage
drinking is bad and wrong and you
shouldn't do it huh don't know stop it
No
saved a life today I did good nah but
seriously don't do none of that
all right so now what I don't even know
what we're doing I think we're trying to
go find the fireflies
so that Ellie here can get initiated but
I mean if if you watch the last of us or
you play the last of us you know what's
happening that's the interesting thing
about this DLC we all know how it ends
because it's kind of a prequel Side
Story I don't know how to describe it
it's a weird feeling knowing exactly
what will happen and you
moving forward anyway le what let me
lift this really two little girls can oh
okay I was about to say a giant steel I
mean oh god damn it I'm not mashing it
again not yeah that's a bad idea you
know what how about we find another way
sounds good yep they're good good job
good thinking good teamwork I applaud
your efforts now what do we have here
yeah the majority of my time in the city
I feel was spelt our I felt was felt
spare I feel was spent indoors or
underground now need to find another way
I'm never good at finding these things
but what yeah we found it together good
job us goat weird words go oh there hey
that's good what exactly are you
pointing at oh yeah that I saw that the
whole time be careful in there yeah you
be careful what am I not know what's
gonna happen I know we know okay now
what you're not Joel you can't lift me
oh you're gonna be smart and unlike see
anything Riley
Oh Oh
how the hell did we never find this
place uh-huh come on I got the perfect
mass for you yeah that cloud looks
familiar
perfect that's sure from where that Sun
like a throwback to an old naughty dog
game huh dude okay check it out cool
wolf man or something town wolf girl
excuse me sometimes that mannequin head
is creepier thank you yeah bad ah
no work yeah rah rah fire oh I gotta
press a button I'm sorry
rawr well Ellie really [ __ ] war yeah
yeah I'm mashing it up for the mass here
now let's see what else this place had
okay we're just gonna walk around like
this now well well well you know that is
nice so um what are we doing eyeballs
good good for the healthy
I don't get it oh I totally forgot they
have no idea what Halloween is they have
no idea what happened in the past that
like just hit me I don't know what ah
again
wow that was yeah that's nice too
yeah way to go you made a fool of
yourself on the whole internet everyone
knows what you just did
yeah that's so strange they have no idea
oh man hey
vampires oh hey I am Count Chocula yeah
sure
whatever you tell yourself actually
count it see um countess Dracula yeah as
adorable as this all is I know that it
has to come to an end soon you define
the purpose of why we are here sorry did
I get in your way I apologize am I still
in your way somehow I apologize further
true horror tales account spirit uh-huh
right I guess I could have just moved
forward at any time
still it's a fascinating thing I mean
you gotta admire the dedication actually
crafting an entire world with its own
universe ah yeah red ones yours I'll be
blue we throw brick whoever breaks all
the windows to their car wait
okay tell me I'm like the brick man okay
all right
loser has to answer questions no sarcasm
okay what is this truth or truth all
right full you're on wait which one was
mine he's mine the red or the blue I
don't remember which one mine was oh
come on
wait no I had that no hang on no I got
this trip
ah this is like a tutorial on how to
throw bricks I know yeah oh yeah burski
she says my thing that's what I say a
bish Murr yeah yeah yeah yeah hoop smash
how you doing good more bricks I guess
at this point most of the batteries
would be dead long dead so I guess
there's no real worry of a car alarm -
how pitifully pathetic yeah ha ha did I
miss one did I miss like driver side
shimmy - jibbety jibbety jibbety bibbidi
oh wait what no put them all back back
back back back I got a fish oh no oh yes
judge mr. [ __ ] master my tougher
windows yeah whatever a loser alright
question time okay
hey look at that um oh that looks like
an important one so what does Marlene
say about my mom
not much I gathered that they were
friends even before the outbreak oh and
she said your mom was a nurse nurse
apparently me like are you didn't fought
a lot but they were close sound familiar
hmm right come on let me show you this
thing we're almost there okay but if you
say I trust you kinda for the most part
am I the only one that thinks it's very
strange that these two girls go
wandering on the mall on their own and
nothing bad happens yeah what are we
doing here you didn't think that one
through one before I should saying it so
you know we thought they only powered
certain areas of the city no yeah no
follow me okay whatever you say just
gonna carry on my way we're gonna have a
nice day I sure hope there isn't a price
to pay so turns out huh the whole city
has power they just flip the circuit
breakers Oh handy then I'm gonna do skip
it back oh that is a big circuit breaker
logically it makes sense the whole city
is wired up it's gonna be a notice we
train hold all it up let's go find out
that's not a good thing it's not not a
good thing
wonder what kind of power they do you
say can't have the regular routes that
Gould like burning coal because that
requires a lot of infrastructure to get
it and go
mm-hmm hydroelectric would make sense
cuz it was a dam in the other one I'm
really glad that you're not dead I mean
I'm glad that we're back together and I
didn't mean it all that stuff I said
before I left
I didn't mean any of it
Riley
you're such a SAP I just started it oh
man are you ready
totally are you kidding
well that's something then that is a
good question
I to wonder how the hell I am going to
be able to get up here Hey look at that
spring 2014 that's almost now okay brick
who wants to get pricked in the dick any
zom zoms do you even have dicks left and
if you are a woman then you're not
qualified in this department please move
forward Terry any way to get this on huh
follow the cables cable Rachel okay
good old life lessons from Joel so this
leads oh I didn't even know I had a gun
oh it is dark in here okay
him oh god [ __ ] cap oh it was a
pretty kitty it was a sweet little kitty
just going on it's a little kitty way
what do you mind that I apologize but
there is something in my eye
there is something in my eye again I'm
just tearing up at all the emotions but
holy hell wait trying to kill me
hello kitty again I'm in I stress
situation oh okay so I think I gotta get
up there no that was wrong over here ah
I'd said my eye I need a pause balls
okay back to normal why'd we stop why'd
you guys stop is there something wrong
with you I have no idea what happened
but anyway continuing on all right
oh the old generator again I remember
this minigame
yeah nothing oh no gasps I don't use the
old gas fetching mechanic eh
let's see what have we got here okay I
can't read that
private Ellis is taking a turn for the
worst he's burning up and he couldn't
keep any of his food down maybe I made a
mistake
maybe the amputation was too late maybe
when I'm not watching him he'll turn in
the infection protocol we did what we
had to do to officer Caulfield who the
hell am I kidding
we murdered Larry Ellis held him down
washed shot him like a [ __ ] dog I
can't get his screams out of my head
Regan please I still have time don't do
this Ellis what have we done what if I
just leave what if I just make a run for
it I'm sorry Ellis
all silliness aside sometimes reality
the situation does creep up that's why I
never understood why people want a
zombie apocalypse like it would be
horrible I think I said this in my last
of us playthrough like it would just be
pure and simple awful from start to
finish
it wouldn't be fun and the vast majority
of everyone who says like I don't know
what's kind of survivor I'd be but I'd
be badass no you'd probably be zom zom
food day one you wouldn't even get
turned into a zombie you just get eaten
up by gang that tasty brains doesn't
work out I would I'm not saying I
wouldn't either I'd probably dead very
first day you've seen me in survival
situations in games alone and in real
life of course I'd be dead immediately
I'd be the first in line for zombie chow
all right I know what would happen I
know exactly what would happen I don't
know if I've said this before in the
Last of Us play three but what happen is
I would call out to all my fans to meet
up with me at one location and then by
the time they got there I'd become as
they'd all become zom zoms and I'd be
stormed and no matter how secure I was I
would be dead with the love of my undead
fans you would all kill me with your
zombie nasaw
good for you did I get a Gascon i have
no idea anyway I'm all out of time for
this one I will continue this very soon
I hope you are enjoying this I know this
isn't for a lot of people but I know
that it was almost required of me to
play this because I said that I would
and I promised it and I'm gonna see it
through to the end so thank you all so
much for watching click the annotation
for movies that I've done and as always
I will see you
in the next video by
since that